so the growing economic impact of
Biden's border crisis a new report from
the center for immigration studies show
nearly three in five illegal immigrants
households are on taxpayer funded
welfare support Steve camarada is the
research director at the center for
immigration cities and he joins us now
so 60% of the folks that are coming here
illegally are on are being supported by
the taxpayer so what happened to all of
these folks saying they're giving to
society
right so what happens is very often
illegal immigrants have us-born children
most uh illegal immigrant headed
households have a us-born child so they
get the benefits on behalf of a us-born
child um the reason that they qualify is
because they're so poor and the reason
they're poor is that most but by no
means all illegal immigrants tend to
have very modest levels of education so
they do work this is not because they
don't work this is because um they work
but they make very low income and I
think what a lot of people don't realize
is if you work but make low income you
qualify for everything from food stamps
to free school lunch to the wick program
to public housing to the Earned Income
Tax Credit so working doesn't preclude
welfare use and what we're seeing is a
lot of illegal immigrants do find jobs
but they're poor and so they and often
their children qualify for these
programs Steve it shouldn't be a
surprise toest though these folks are
come into the country illegally so they
don't have the proper doc a many of them
don't speak English and many of them are
paid under the table and the reason why
they're paid under the table because
it's it's cheap labor um you know
Americans would do those jobs but they
want a fair wage the the these people
aren't on they're on a slave based labor
system where no one reasonable person
would take those jobs for that pay right
well that certainly happens and just by
their presence here they tend to lower
wages because they're increasing the
supply of workers at the bottom end of
the labor market however the difference
between what happens when illegal
immigrants have work authorization and
don't isn't enormous if the illegal
immigrant themselves has very modest
skills and that's often very true so
again yes it's true that when they work
off the book sometimes they work for
less but it's really the case that
they're just very uh very modestly
educated and that's one of the main
reasons they use so much welfare and
because they're poor many states like
new York and California step in and
cover illegal immigrants with welfare
programs too and that's what we're
picking up partly in in the study as
well so it isn't just the presence of
the children but it's the political
pressure because you have all these poor
people in your state so Steve you've
been tracking this and I know you're
just researcher do you see any appetite
in Congress to get something done
because there's a magnet if if you if
you're looking at this program or these
programs and you're saying look 60% of
us have a shot of being on this you'll
keep coming to the
country right there has to be some
effect for this right however I do think
it's fair to say most illegal immigrants
come to America not so much to get
welfare but to work but they have
children they struggle and then turn to
the American taxpayer for support it's
going to be very hard once you've let
people in so many of them with modest
education and low income not to end up
having them use these programs because
uh as is the case we give automatic
citizenship to their us-born children
you either enforce the law and don't
have so many illegal immigrants and and
reduce the problem or you accept the
cost if you're going to be letting a lot
of unskilled people into your country
what a novel idea Steve just enforce the
law um I I hope they're watching we
appreciate you breaking down the numbers
with us thanks for having me you got to
Steve I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis